foreign
Georgia what's up Carol
hey it's so nice to be talking with you
today thank you for taking my call oh
goodness thank you for calling me and
I'm kind of in a singing mood still I'm
trying to stop Kelly says it's annoying
people write in comments and you quit
singing is my saying bad all right no
you're good all right what's up Carol
okay uh I'm trying to figure out how to
lose weight and keep it off permanently
After experiencing those sexual trauma
oh gosh what happened
next story I was raped when I was 16
years old I was being a size five seven
after years of yo-yo dieting I'm now 44.
uh yeah for half my life and then a size
18 20. in the past I could lose some
weight however every time I received any
kind of attention from a man as little
as a look or a smile or anytime I was
planning an event trip holiday get
together Etc I would gain weight and
didn't realize I was doing this to
myself until a couple of years ago
and now that I I know I still cannot
seem to break the cycle and on top of
that I was in a vehicle accident six
years ago that caused a lot of issues
with my body making it even harder to
exercise or do any kind of physical
activity any length of time without
being in excruciating pain
so I'm in desperate need of your help Dr
Don Delaney Delaney sorry yeah oh you're
okay
my wife says my name wrong too still
after 25 years that's fine
hmm
I guess I'll just start with I'm so
sorry that happened
I'm so sorry that somebody took that
everything away from you
especially taking away how safe you feel
inside your own body
um
and I'm also sorry for
almost 30 years of
just painful loneliness right
I'm so sorry
um my experience is is
you're going to need somebody different
than me but I'm going to walk you I'm
gonna hold your hand and walk you to
that person okay is that cool
that's perfect okay
um
so most common this is what the
literature would tell me okay is that
after a sexual assault
there can be a couple of different paths
when it comes to weight gain
sometimes it is
I want to hide inside myself I want to
disappear in a crowded room kind of like
my daughter she's seven she'll put her
hair over her eyes and kind of feel like
she's disappeared even though she's
standing right there
I'm kind of disappear
or I can put some some safety between me
and the outside world
there's often another piece of this
train that I think is is more Insidious
and that it's somehow some way the story
gets twisted up inside of somebody that
this is what they get
that this is what they deserve
it's almost a form of self-punishment
look at what you did last time look at
what you allowed to happen last time
look at the role you played in what
happened last time you that's what you
get
so if you've honestly looked I mean it
sounds like you've I mean you're way
ahead of most folks that I sit down with
in this with this this challenge
when you look back and you go oh gosh
every time every time I get close to
somebody every time I start to be around
other people
I just without even thinking I start
using food to numb out and then it's got
some pretty significant Health
consequences for me
um when you look back
um
what is your body trying to keep you
safe from
being hurt
okay
is there any sort of guilt here or are
you able to separate yourself from any
sort of this is on somebody else
somebody else took this from you that
you didn't play a role in that
I'm sure the other skill
what's the guilt from
tell me the guilt story
I guess
it wasn't a person that worked with my
dad if he'd come to the house so I mean
he was like oh uh
I would consider a family friend but I
guess if I wouldn't have got in the
vehicle nope nope nope nope it's gonna
stop you right there Carol
no you're a kid
you're a kid
that man stole from you
okay
foreign
does it make you feel vulnerable naked
on a street corner if you will
yeah exposed okay
I mean of course when I'm bigger like I
am now I won't
to lose the weight of course if you want
to be healthy but then when I get there
if I get any look or attention that
scares me yeah
all right I'm going to walk you through
a few steps and I'm going to direct you
where you need to go next okay
okay all right
um and so for people listening by the
way
it's I I totally get it it's very easy
to to think man
you'll feel so much better if you're
right
and
it's a feeling of Terror that if you
haven't been through some sort of sexual
assault or sexual trauma that it's hard
to even put into words
fact your body takes over and you even
you even spoke of it as an out-of-body
experience almost you wake up a month
later and you've put on 35 pounds
right
it's almost so automated or so
mind-numbing that your body starts to
save your life from yourself because
it's so put a pin in Intimacy in
relationships that it goes running right
uh-huh okay
all right so here's step one
I want you to hear what I'm gonna say
and I'm going to be pretty direct
because we only have a few minutes okay
and normally I'd be a lot slower to say
some of the things I'm going to say but
they're pretty direct okay
is that cool and a lot of them you
probably know but maybe no one's ever
said them to you before okay
this is not keeping you safe
and in fact
this is killing you slowly
I agree completely okay
the second thing is and this is going to
be hard and this is going to be
something you have to unpack with a
counselor do you promise you will talk
to somebody
yes okay
we are going to commit from this day
forward
that we will not give that man one more
second of your life
yes no more
no more keeping ourselves safe from that
guy
surely he's long dead by now
hopefully okay
he does not get one more inch of real
estate in your heart anymore
he's still winning
he still cast a shadow and that ends
today
okay
yes now I know that's easy to say out
loud and there's going to take some
significant trauma counseling to work
through it not significant in time I
think you can do it relatively quickly
over the course of 10 or 11 or 12 weeks
but
significant like it's gonna be tough
it'll be tough
but if anybody knows tough it's Carol in
Georgia right
amen that's right I'm fighting you ain't
no way okay step two
I want you to recognize you were not
safe then
when that predator of a man came into
your house
and took from you your innocence your
safety
your ability to get close he stole that
from you
you weren't safe then but you're safe
now
and that sentence is going to be
critical to you getting well
so when your body starts to try to
protect you in the present
from a thing that happened 30 years ago
we're going to stop and we're gonna say
out loud I wasn't safe then but I'm safe
right now
I'm Carol from Georgia I'm safe right
now
okay
yes all right
you're gonna have to decide over time to
catch those feelings in progress in
action and sometimes that will be
halfway through a cheeseburger I don't
know what your food of choice is mine is
candy and cheeseburgers I catch myself
halfway through a cheeseburger and I'll
throw the whole thing out oh my gosh I
am mindlessly doing this
I've been on the phone with somebody in
the middle of a business call trying to
make a thing and I pulled into a
drive-through I'm just going down I'm
going down a rabbit hole here
caught it and then I asked myself what's
my body trying to protect me from oh
I'm kind of ashamed that I might not get
the speaking gig or they they can't meet
my rate or whatever the thing is that my
body's trying to protect me from
it's just a practice to catch it
you can't see this unless you're
watching because we're on the phone but
I actually have like a a journal that I
carry with me that's just the thoughts I
just write them down
that way I can just examine them is this
true or is this not true
and then over time with the counselor
you're going to learn some new traits
some new skills instead of
eating those feelings we're going to
walk those feelings
we're going to call a friend those
feelings we're going to show up to a
groups those feelings
we're going to read a book those
feelings we have a cup of coffee a cup
of tea we're going to figure out other
avenues for those feelings does that
make sense
yes
here's where that's a huge paradigm
shift for you you're not broken there's
nothing wrong with you your body's doing
exactly what it should it is trying to
protect you from that hell ever
happening again and it's done a great
job right it's done a shop
and it's cost you everything right yes
yes okay so what we have to do is we
have to open up our toolkit of which
there's only one tool and that is avoid
all relationships period
okay that worked that kept us safe and
it's killed us too so we're gonna put
some new Tools in that bag
that's it
and I don't want you to look at this as
though you have some sort of character
issue or some sort of willpower issue
now you don't understand you just need
some different Tools in that bag that
you got to practice using that's all
okay okay
I want you to honor your body for having
kept you safe for for 30 years
I'm okay and be really pissed off that
it shows that way all right that's right
they could have chose Marathon running
that uh I saw recently there's a
significant number of of
um endurance athletes that also had
significant trauma
okay
it's equally un I mean it's equally not
good
but it's just the body's response and so
hey buddy you kept me safe
I really hate how you did this but you
kept me safe
right
uh-huh I got this from my good buddy Sal
DiStefano who works with the Mind pump
guys and I want you to hear me really
closely
you cannot hate your body into being
healthy
you can't disgust yourself into being
healthy you can't
you have to honor it you've got me safe
thank you you thank you
and now we're going to learn safety in a
new way because this way is going to
kill me
and it's going to keep me lonely it's
going to keep me filling the blame step
three you're gonna have to begin
practicing becoming aware when you grab
food when you're isolating
and this isn't about fighting yourself
this is about one word awareness
that's it
okay
and if you will do the work of writing
them down in a journal and when I say
Journal like nine bucks at Walmart have
somebody go get it for you right nine
bucks
um
as you write them down you'll start to
see a pattern
every time my dad calls I reach over and
grab something to eat
every time it gets past eight o'clock
and I'm lonely I grab something to eat
every time I finish I get nervous at
work or whatever the thing is
and those will be your trigger points
curious why is my body trying to protect
me from that
you see what I'm saying and I want you
to hear how light My Touch is on all
this you have fought yourself for 30
years right
yes you've hated yourself for 30 years
right
you've been grossed out for 30 years
right yes see we make can we make one
agreement that's not working
right let's try something else
yes
it's the same thing I tell parents who
are screaming at their kids and
screaming at their kids screaming at
their kids take out the trash take out
trash make her bed
when I finally say hey that's not
working what if we tried something else
and that's all I'm asking you 've tried
the hammer method you tried the screen
method you've tried that I hate you
method you've tried the starvation
method you've tried to all work this off
method let's start with the I love Carol
method
and thank God for keeping me safe
yes
and now let's move on step four is going
to be to seek out a daily weekly group
of people that you care about whether
that's an Overeaters Anonymous whether
that's a counselor whether that's a
group of women that get together for
coffee somewhere at a local place
I'm convinced beyond a shadow of a doubt
there is no healing especially from
trauma and isolation you have to be with
other people
okay what makes trauma so ugly is it
makes the one it makes oxygen poisonous
it makes oxygen feel poisonous
right
when you start getting close to people
that's when your body says run right
that's what you're gonna have to go
through that's the alarm you're gonna
have to head directly into kind of like
your kitchen that smoke alarm goes off
you don't run out in the yard you go see
what the alarm what's setting the alarm
off
all right that's what we're doing here
okay you know I mean with a group of
friends once a week that sets off your
alarms cool then I'm gonna make sure
we're doing that
or I'm gonna go to Overeaters Anonymous
I'm gonna go to uh whatever group I'm
gonna go be with people
slowly slowly slowly at first right
yes
and I'm gonna suggest and this is going
to give me some hate on the internet
saying I don't care
um I don't think it's time for exercise
yet
okay okay
I don't think it's I don't think we're
there yet if you could go for a walk
every day I think that would be dramatic
for your body and your mind and your
soul
but if you can okay don't
cool
perfect
um you may be ready to rock and roll
like no no I want to get an exercise
program and get this get go to physical
therapy and get some PT and get this
pain under control cool that's great
but I don't want you to try to look in
the in the mirror and stare at yourself
and hate yourself forward on that
treadmill
I want you to think we've been kept safe
for this long now we're moving into part
two that took way longer than we thought
but we're moving into part two which is
I love this body that has kept me safe
for 30 years so much I'm gonna make sure
it's around for another 40.
right I am exercising because I get to
because that guy has not one more inch
inside of my heart
he will not keep me isolated anymore he
will not keep me alone anymore anymore
anymore
here's step five this is the hardest
part have you ever been to counseling
yet
oh okay
most of my family and friends don't
even grief Demands a witness
as the great David Kessler says you have
to say these things out loud and here's
what I almost guarantee has happened
inside of you
when you told me what happened
I'd be willing to bet your shoulders
dropped a little bit and it felt
and then over the course of this call
your body has filled back up with it
with with
air oh my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh oh
my gosh is that right
and then when you get off this call
you're gonna have a I can't believe I
said that I can't believe I said that I
can't believe I said that
you're gonna have to find somebody that
you can sit down and be honest and tell
the story to so I want you and your
local community I want you to reach out
to somebody
and say
I was sexually assaulted and raped as a
teenager and it's continuing to
um
have a powerful hold on me into my 40s
and I'm ready to let this go I would
like to explore trauma counseling what
does that mean might be EMDR
it might mean Bodywork which is what I
had done did and it was extraordinary
that's that's a whole other conversation
we could have another time
it's it might be a some sort of
adult-centric seeking safety program it
might be an rdbt program it might be any
number of things the modality I don't
care so much about but somebody that
will walk through and teach you a set of
skills for self managing when your body
takes off on you and then head back
through that trauma
and then the Peace and Freedom on the
other side of it
and there's going to be guilt and I
can't believe it went on this all that's
part of the healing
but man
you're worth all of it
we're going to clip this I'm going to
send it to you Carol
um just so that you don't have to wait
for a month until this show comes out
um I'm also going to send you a copy of
my book own your past change your future
and I want you to read that book it
doesn't speak specifically to White game
but it does talk about healing from
trauma just the path out and how these
stories get lodged in US
and I want you to before today is over I
want you to call counselor and I want
you to call one or two women that will
go out and have coffee with you
and if you're brave you can say the
story out loud you don't just say names
you don't say anything like that but you
can say the story out loud and be heard
for the first time
it'll be scary it'll be hard and
that's the first step towards this not
holding you anymore then I'm gonna grip
on you anymore I'm free from this
I am free
I'm so grateful for you Carol I'm so
proud of you I'm so proud of you for not
giving up on you and saying all right
cool 44. today is when everything
changes
foreign